hello I'm Kimberly Leonard at the high
court in London for the Sky News Daily
Prince Harry arrived again here this
morning to the world's waiting media
he's now finished giving evidence and
only moments ago as we're recording this
he left
camera crews are doing their final lives
the photographers are sending their
pictures off and packing up in the
crowds have left too
Prince Harry spent a day and a half up
against one of the country's toughest
cases the mirror groups Barrister Mr
Andrew Green and today we got even more
details about Prince Harry's case that
the newspaper group obtained information
about him illegally he told the court
about a tracking device he found on his
ex-chelsea Davies car he said
photographers knew he was meeting
presenter Caroline Flack and questioned
how they had that information
the mirror group denies the claims
our team has been here for each day of
this hearing so if you want to catch up
you can find our previous podcasts where
you found this one
foreign
I'm joined Now by Sky's Royal
correspondent Laura bundock and our
reputation
who's been tweeting all day from the
court and media lawyer Jonathan code
thank you all so much to you Laura let's
start with you day two of the
cross-examination what was the tone of
the day-to-date well I bumped into
someone who'd been in court with Harry
first thing in the morning and they said
it felt like it had his Weetabix he kind
of marched in he Strode in there was a
much more confident Prince Harry I think
it had been a big day he'd handled the
pressure I think people clearly happy
with how he'd handled the pressure
yesterday he was calm he was composed he
didn't lose his Rag and I think that had
been a real worry as to how he would
cope with the the atmosphere in that
Court it is intense so are you one of
the few people who are actually in court
for the entire cross-examination
what was it like in there just give us a
sense it was seven hours of quite
arduous cross-examination I think the
scene was really quite something to see
it was the King's son versus King's
Council Casey is like the top form of
Barrister that you can have in this
country and Andrew Green is a formidable
Barrister he's also slightly
intimidating he's got a big presence
about him and he was questioning Prince
Harry in a very robust manner over a day
and a half things he was talking to him
about were really intimate one of the
things he talked about today was Harry
visiting Spearmint Rhino strip club it
was all very personal
um but I thought Prince Harry handled
himself really well over the past seven
hours we think of Harriet as this quite
colorful character but in court he was
controlled he was measured and he kept
his calm so how was the courtroom set up
where was he where were you who else was
in there they caught 15 of the roles
building at the high court is a fairly
intimate space there are about two rows
of journalists one for each news
organizer and then a couple of members
of public some of whom have been queuing
from 4 30 this morning to try and get a
spot in the public Gallery which in
reality was just a couple of seats
Prince Harry was sat on the left at the
far end of the Court by the judge he was
sat in front of a lot of legal documents
and bundles and he had a computer screen
in front of him where he could see some
of those bundles but if you're imagining
a scene from perhaps Ally McBeal or
something with dark wooden mahogany I'm
afraid it's a lot more modern inside
there and
um the setup is a little bit more like a
sixth form College it doesn't
necessarily feel like the traditional
courtrooms that we might imagine but
there were of course the barristers in
their wigs and gowns but people weren't
kind of patrolling the room as you often
see in the films it's a very controlled
very stage managed environment and there
were members of the public in there
weren't there what were they doing
um trying to speak to Prince Harry in
the breaks a couple of them had brought
copies of his autobiography spare hoping
to get in a autograph
um some of them shouted over to him that
he was a hero to keep going to keep
fighting
um he just smiled he didn't interact
with any of them Laura when Harry was
giving his evidence today he kept
talking to the judge didn't he
how did that go down shall we say well
it's unusual because that's not what
someone in the witness stand is supposed
to they're meant to be just they don't
ask questions they're meant to be
answering questions and he was reigned
back in a little bit a couple of times
when the Murray group Barris as Andrew
Green said you're asking me a question
I've reminded you about that so that
stopped um but yeah he sort of turn turn
to the judge and maybe it was a nerves
thing maybe it was sort of a don't quite
know the protocol here but that's not
the kind of thing you'd normally see in
cases here but you did always get a
sense that and maybe it's because he's
being addressed as Prince Harry that
this was a slightly different category
of claimants I mean that was the point
very early on that his Barrister had
said regarding why the fact you know why
he wasn't here on Monday he had these
travel and security issues that the
other claimants don't have Etc
um but you know this is unusual he is he
is a prince he's a senior royal son of
the king as Sarah was saying and here he
is at the high court so there was you
know the last Royal that got a special
seat made of velvet when he headed with
the 7 as Prince of Wales gave evidence
you know way back when
um there wasn't a special velvet seat
Prince Harry but I think you know there
were no exceptions made for him but
there was an awareness of who he was
so Jonathan what happened today what was
Andrew Green's attack today well it was
more or less the same through the day
and that's not being critical of him
so there were 33 articles and it was uh
Andrew Green's job to
undermine the prince's case that these
articles must have been the product of
our lawful information gathering once or
twice the case he made his ground and
Harry showing I thought very good level
sense and courtesy accepted that he was
probably right about that but on a
number of occasions I think that the
prince studies were Ground really well
and the most striking moment for me was
a an article about he was on holiday
with Chelsea Davey what the newspapers
found out was his flight details going
home now very firmly he said there is no
way legitimately that could have been
obtained it's a closely guarded secret
nobody's told about it and the reason
for that is because of the security risk
and at that point I I think the KC was
was a bit wrong footed because he was
not able to put forward to the judge any
all terms of explanation for that so I
think that was Harry's best moment and
this isn't just about phone hacking is
it this is about a lot of other unlawful
Gathering of information blagging one of
them yes it is I mean blagging is is in
case anyone doesn't know is where you uh
normally make a telephone call in to say
to a hospital or or to uh to an airline
and lie through your teeth and try and
get out of them information which they
wouldn't otherwise give out
the center of this case has to be
understood not just about those 33
articles the CL the basis of the claim
is that
princes private information had been
stolen effectively through unlawful
means now whether it turned up in the
newspaper or not is relevant but the
fundamental thing is that he was
unlawfully eavesdropped on in various
ways and therefore his privacy was
invaded and that was a wrong which he
suffered despite being a senior member
of the royal family just to reiterate
that the mayor does deny all the claims
sorry when you were in there and you
were listening to all of this you picked
up on it earlier these are moments what
20 years ago very intimate moments how
did Prince Harry react to basically
reliving them and reliving his reaction
to them it was clear on his face that he
was uncomfortable I mean nobody likes
talking about their ex-girlfriend or
boyfriend and he was being asked very
intimate questions about the breakdown
of a relationship with a woman that he
clearly loved and he looked weary he
looked tired but he was answering
questions for seven hours and if you
take into account that he potentially
only flew in on Sunday evening from from
LA or West Coast Flight after a
two-year-old's birthday party and then
had one day to prepare before what would
have been unlike any other Royal
interview we'd ever seen before I mean
this isn't a chat with James Corden and
a bus in La where you're talking about
um soft questions these are really
probing and hard-hitting questions and
deeply deeply personal and there were
several moments that I saw him
um heavily sigh or blow out his cheeks
we often see Prince Harry you know he
has that characteristic biting of his
bottom lip he always does that when he's
awkward or he feels a bit uncomfortable
he said before an interview he doesn't
necessarily feel comfortable speaking in
public we've heard a lot of him speak
over the past couple of months and I
thought his voice was really markedly
different from the voice that we heard
narrating his audio book and spare he
was very quiet and I think
self-conscious initially but his
confidence built up over the preceding
hours
he could have settled he did not have to
go oh yeah he would have been I'm sure
he would have been offered I mean
Jonathan will know better than me but he
would have been offered large sums of
money not to have this happen absolutely
they're absolutely certain and I think
one of the reasons why um Jane care was
caught off guard was that my best guess
is that when she wrote her witness
statement No One expected that this
trial was going to happen and so she may
have written it thinking well you know
that's that's it you know my job's done
hold that thought I'm going to bring
Sarah in to explain who Jane care is
she's the former Royal editor of America
and she was um the second witness called
after Prince Harry after he left seven
hours of them giving evidence himself
you might have thought he wanted to
leave the court but he didn't he went
and sat next to his solicitors and he
was very keen to hear her evidence
because she is the author or the bylined
author of 10 of the 33 articles that
this whole case is centered upon and the
tone in the courtroom instantly changed
it was very combative it was suddenly
David Sherborne and who's Harry's
Barrister on his feet and quizzing this
journalist about how she got her stories
and it was really quite tense in there
and it was interesting to see Harry
sitting making notes watching
proceedings let's go back um to Jonathan
now because there were specific
questions
um to Jane Kerr about the title she gave
herself in her State well yes I was
slightly puzzled by that
um I mean I'm not going to criticize
David Chairman's cross-examination
because he's a masterat it wasn't
obvious to me what he was getting at but
the point was that as he explained an
important part of her career history
which David chairborne thought was
important and should have been in her
witness State wasn't there and she
wasn't really able to explain why it
wasn't there what he did is he
contrasted her profile on some website
which which made a big point of the fact
that she was a news editor with the fact
that that didn't appear in the witness
statement so that was the second and the
first well Michelle was you didn't want
to come here the second one was it
doesn't look like you were really owning
up to the full extent of your
responsibility that was David's point
you were kind of trying to downplay the
extent to which you were responsible uh
and I think that's the point that he was
trying to make to the judge it's going
to I think turn much more on how she
gets on in cross-examination than Prince
Harry because in the end Prince Harry
wasn't doing it I mean obviously we're
not assuming that it was done but for
the sake of this podcast let's assume
that Harry's right well again the mirror
denies all claims entirely the mirror
denies all claims and we'll find out
what the judge has to say in due course
but the significance of Jane care is
that she was the one that was
commissioning apparently 900 times one
particular agency commissioning the work
which Prince Harry says was done
unlawfully and one of the most
extraordinary moments for me was when
David Sherborne said well how did you
know
when you said in your witness statement
you know I never
instructed anybody to do anything
illegal well how did you know
and she said well I never thought to ask
and he said Are you seriously saying
that of all the information that you get
in that looks private it never occurred
to you that there might have been some
unlawful means of collecting it and the
answer to it will know it never occurred
to me and I think at that point the
judge's jaw probably hit the desk it was
always going to be hard for her because
the whole purpose of this
cross-examination is for him to try and
prove that if she was authorizing all
these invoices did she not ever think to
ask is the activity I'm authorizing here
legal because we were told about this
procurement policy that mirror group had
that meant you can't sign off clearly I
mean it would make sense but you can't
sign an invoice if it's for something
really dodgy something illegal something
potentially criminal and he was like
well you never asking and she said I
think the answers were hard for her she
was saying well I assume not had no
reason to believe and he was like well
you had your own systems we within The
Newsroom where you could do a search on
somebody and you could get an address
potentially one system called Cameo came
up and said why would you need to engage
other people to get any more information
what more could you be doing and the the
dots he's trying to join up there is
that these are the sorts of people who
could do bigger bigger bits of kind of
digging using he alleges these unlawful
means so finding out maiden names
potentially of parents or family members
and that can give you access to
information or the blagging the you the
deception the deceitful way of kind of
using someone's Identity or information
to get that private kind of content and
that's what he was trying to prove with
her and she didn't really have a reason
as to why she'd engage these agencies
these people without carrying out the
sort of due checks on them it was an
assumption on her part that it was all
above board okay
um let's take a quick breather to digest
all of that and we'll come back and
discuss the wider implications of Harry
hello again well I'm back here
um with Laura Jonathan and Sarah and
Sarah I want to start with you you were
in there for the two days of his
cross-examination how do you think he
did
well he didn't mess up he didn't get
heated he kept his cool I thought it was
really striking at the end of his kind
of session today David Sherborne asked
him how he felt having to divulge all
this information in open court for so
long and Harry at that point almost lost
his composure he he paused he looked
down and he said it's a lot his face was
flushed at this point and he lowered his
face behind a screen but the very next
question that he answers his voice broke
and I think that was the moment really
where we really saw him lose his
composure a little bit and we saw just
how upset he must have been going
through all of this stuff that had
happened to him over 20 years ago and
you really saw how how much of a toll
it's taking on him emotionally he didn't
need to come to court he put himself
forward as a witness and the statement
he kept saying again again in court was
that he wished that more journalists had
been doing saying also Jonathan do you
think he's done enough to prove his case
well if you're asking whether his own
testimony was enough well no but it was
never expected to be enough doing my
best to read the judge
doing my best to look at the evidence as
best I can as a media lawyer
I think he has now it's important to
understand that there are 33 articles
now Harry gets a win if he even makes
his ground on only one
obviously he'll be disappointed if it's
only one but the difficulty for the
mirror is they've got to knock down all
33. Laura The Wider context within the
royal family how do you think that
they're looking at this will they be
watching this will they be reading the
news on this what do you think their
reaction is Prince When he'll be very
glad he settled his case against
he will not have wanted to go through
that and he clearly chose not to um look
no in seriousness I think they will be
they will be aware of what was going on
but probably listening with their sort
of hands part over their eyes just in
case because let's be honest we've heard
a lot from Harry haven't we in recent
months you know he has been talking at
length about some very difficult awkward
moments and descriptions of things the
royal family I'm sure would rather he
hadn't mentioned and when it came to
them and what was said about them I
don't think there was anything that
would have set off any alarm Bells not
the likes of when we started to read
spare and how he viewed his stepmother
the queen all of this it wasn't about
them really it was about him and
obviously their names some of them were
brought into this but not not in the
negative way that we've heard in the
past so I think there will be a relief
that we've heard Harry speak and there's
no kind of big moment for them
um but they won't have liked it it's
this isn't how they do things but this
isn't about the damages this isn't about
the money for Harry this is about the
moment basically he might win here who
knows we're not going to know for a very
long time what does he actually gain
from it that's the bigger question is he
going to bring about some kind of big
reform of the media he said I want to
change the media landscape it's my
life's work this is a very big part of
that there are two other cases obviously
this is the first one and a very
significant one but even if it's a win
has he won the bigger thing there to
bring about the reform the change that
he thinks as he puts it in his witness
statement will benefit us all that's the
bigger question here not sure he's going
to win the court of public opinion he
won't be wasn't about that in the UK I
think he feels it's too influenced by
the newspapers so you don't publish nice
stories about him for various reasons
and agendas but where does it leave him
where does it leave Megan as well he
might want to restart her sort of career
her role in the US as well all this
matters and it is important so there are
much bigger things going on here as well
okay so Jonathan what happens if Harry
doesn't win
it'll be very hard for him I think you
strongly sense that the passion has
started to build when he followed his
mum's coffin who he felt had been driven
to her death by the tabloids he's taken
the most enormous risk he's invested his
own personal in that Integrity his own
judgment in this so I think it will be a
bitter blow for him if he doesn't win
then maybe it'll make him rethink the
claims that he's got against Associated
newspapers and the Publishers of the sun
and the sun on Sunday
and the broader ramifica
if he does win one of the points he
makes very strongly in his witness
statement is that we don't have a
properly regulated press so I think he
will hope that this may be a sufficient
prompt to the politicians to go back to
the question of press regulation
my thanks to Laura Sarah and Jonathan
and to you for listening to the Sky News
Daily with me Kimberly Leonard this
episode was produced by Annie Joyce with
Sydney peed the editor is Paul stanworth
and just to let you know there's been a
Sky News TV program on each evening at
nine reflecting on the day's Court
proceedings and you can watch those back
on our YouTube channel